I want to talk about the restrict act
because it was billed as a ban on Tick
Tock but the weird thing is it doesn't
even mention Tick-Tock in this Chinese
own act in the bill so what is this
really about is it about restricting you
know Tick Tock that's not mentioned in
it or is this really a power ground what
are your thoughts on this people should
pay really close attention to the
restrict act because the the Democrats
and Republicans that have have
introduced this legislation are trying
to Market it as something that it's not
it does ban Tick Tock it makes it
illegal for Americans to use Tick Tock
but it does a whole lot more than that
it gives power unfettered power to
unelected bureaucrats in the Commerce
Department to tell us what social media
apps we are or are not allowed to use it
gives them access unfettered access to
our data our browsing history how we're
using different apps on our phones and
it basically criminalizes the use of of
vpns with some pretty serious
consequences and they're doing all this
in the name of National Security Now
this sounds a whole lot like what we saw
with the Patriot Act we as the American
people need to be smart enough to not
fall into this trap again where
ultimately we have again people who took
an oath to support and defend our
constitution our civil liberties our
rights but they are hell-bent on taking
those rights away and Dangerously in
this bill the restrict act not even
allowing us to challenge their actions
through our court system yeah this is a
very serious bill that threatens the
very Foundation of our democracy and our
our god-given rights that are enshrined
in the Constitution and we we cannot
allow them to do this you know what's
you know what's even more scary that
co-signers like Lindsey Graham didn't
even know they had co-signed on this
bill that these these big decisions that
are affecting our civil liberties and
our freedom are being decided by a bunch
of staffers
um instead of actual Senators it was
embarrassing and humiliating and he
should be embarrassed about that that he
should be and that is where we have to
hold these elected leaders they work for
the people we're the ones who get to
hire and fire them and we have to hold
them accountable to do their job the
restrict act are better known as The
Tick Tock bill is a wild trojan horse
under the ACT if you're caught using a
VPN to use tick tock after they ban it
you're gonna get slapped with a one
million dollar fine and get thrown in
prison for 25 years and it's not just
Tick Tock this will apply to any app
made by Foreign adversaries that they
decide to ban and who are the foreign
adversaries any country the government
decides to slap that label on that means
whatever foreign app or foreign Tech the
Department of Commerce wants to ban they
can ban it this bill also gives a lot of
power to unelected officials and if you
violate the law well you can be tried in
a literal secret Court quote gag order
secret fisa Court proceedings public
information blackouts and special
administrative exemptions if that all
sounds familiar to the post-911 era
you'll get where this is going and guess
who's pushing this bill the White House
itself the White House endorsed the
restrict act on Tuesday calling it a
systematic framework for addressing
technology LG based threats to the
security and safety of Americans
no matter what your thoughts on Tick
Tock are if this bill or a bill like it
passes we are gonna be in deep trouble
and here's what you have to know this
bill isn't really about banning Tick
Tock it's never about what they say it
is instead this bill would give enormous
and terrifying new powers to the federal
government to punish American citizens
and regulate how they communicate with
one another it's in fact a far far
broader the restrict act proposes to
Grant the Commerce Department additional
investigative and punitive Powers
regarding all information and telecom
companies connected to a foreign
adversary if they pose undue and
unacceptable risk to U.S national
security or U.S citizens whatever that
means
that is very truly broad oh yeah that's
vague as you could possibly have it well
that's that's broader than
um Barn I mean yeah I was the broad side
of it yeah it's very broad um
foreign
[Music]
of the nootropic supplements I take is
Alpha Brain by Joe Rogan's company on it
and as it turns out the shipping
software on it uses is called ship
station as the chief of operations of
onitsun ship station fundamentally
transformed the company and allowed us
to scale to where we are today that's
because shipstation is the fastest most
affordable way to ship products to your
customers it lets you find the lowest
shipping rate saving you up to 84 from
Top carriers like UPS USPS and DHL
Express while letting you streamline
everything simply connect your selling
Channel and then you can manage all of
your shipping you can set up automations
custom branding shipstation will
instantly update the tracking
information on your selling channel for
you and you'll even get free
comprehensive onboarding support to get
you shipping faster right away so what
are you waiting for use the same
shipping software that Ana uses by going
to shipstation.com for a 60-day free
trial that's two months of Cheaper
stress-free shipping completely for free
go to shipstation.com right now with the
link below thanks to shipstation for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
the restrict Act is intentionally made
to be very vague and flexible quote to
authorize the Secretary of Commerce to
review and prohibit certain transactions
between persons in the United States and
foreign adversaries and for other
purposes what other purposes you may ask
we don't know and that's kind of the
point the people enforcing this could
bend a lot to fit whatever agenda they
want and starting out the bill would
specifically Target these six countries
China Cuba Iran North Korea Russia and
Venezuela under President Nicolas Maduro
if any sort of Technology from these
countries is sold to 1 million Americans
or more in a year the Department of
Commerce would have the right to
investigate and mitigate any risks
associated with it and by mitigate they
mean ban the app outrights or force them
to sell the business to an American
company I don't know about you but that
sounds very much like a free market to
me and if they think someone is
violating the restrict acts they have
all the power to authorize additional
surveillance of U.S citizens online
activity so more surveillance under the
bill the Commerce Secretary can demand
information from any party to a
transaction or holding under review or
investigation in theory a company
designated under the bill such as Tick
Tock could be required to cough up user
data during these investigations so not
only could the government ban Tick Tock
for collecting data on American citizens
they could also go to tick tock and
force them to share their data with them
before they're banned but isn't this
exactly what they're mad about China
over the fact that China can make Tech
talk hand over U.S data at any given
moment this bill will give the American
government that exact same power so what
this tells us is that the US government
isn't against authoritarianism they're
just a guess that when it's not them
that has the authoritarian power and
that's not where it ends according to
the eff a digital Rights group giving
the Commerce Department broad authority
to impose crushing criminal penalties on
any person trying to evade a mitigation
measure is dangerous for example in the
case of a mitigation measure that bars
the importation of tick tock into the US
it authorizes penalties including 25
years of prison time for anyone who
brings tiktok into the us whether by use
of a VPN or downloading it while in
another country that's right if there is
restrict at passes and they ban Tick
Tock you could literally go to prison
for downloading Tick Tock through a VPN
and the same thing goes for any Tech
created or run outside of America and if
the government decides to ban some
random app or program they don't even
have to explain themselves either
because according to the acts actions
taken by the president and the Secretary
of Commerce under this act shall not be
subjected to administrative review or
traditional review in any federal court
except that's otherwise provided in this
section so at the flick of a wrist they
can ban any Tech they want and would not
owe the American public any explanation
whatsoever but if you thought it ended
there oh you're sadly mistaken
interference and manipulation of federal
elections which could mean you're just
skeptical or you're gullible and you
bought into some conspiracy theories and
you're talking about them and instead of
just being able to just talk like a
nonsense person you you get jacked man
this is all so open to interpretation
yeah impact to the country's critical
infrastructure and digital economy end
digital economy is included in there
like what does that mean if if Elon
posts a Dogecoin uh image immediately
Dogecoin goes up right doesn't that
impact the digital economy so what does
that mean yeah I don't know so what if
he says the crypto is bull Because he
believes it but doesn't that impact the
digital economy yeah they could arrest
but do the makers of this bill have
anything to say about this nope they say
that this bill isn't that bad that if
Tick Tock gets banned things will be
okay another Tick Tock copycat would
just pop up and take his place and the
mainstream media is just eating it up
the problem with legislation right is
not what they do it's what they write
down that they could do and then slowly
frog boil over time that's why there's
so much concern over this and the
perfect example of this is the Patriot
Acts
[Music]
after 9 11 the American public was so
enraged so angry and rightfully so that
they were willing to do anything to
accept anything that the government
peddled as the solution which was when
the government was able to pass the
Patriot Act without so much as any
opposition the Patriot Act famously
allowed the NSA to spy on millions of
Americans in secret without needing any
warrants or oversights and it put
America right up there with the Chinese
government in terms of surveillance
power but then on March 15 2020 section
215 of the Patriot Act expired and
suddenly all those Provisions that made
spying on America's legal went down with
it without the Patriarchs the government
had to go back to manually getting a
warrant for every single person they
wanted to spy on which is a huge hassle
if you're trying to monitor the masses
so that's why the government has been
patiently waiting for the next Crisis
the next mass panic that they can use to
slip through yet another overreaching
bill with a catchy name which is where
Tick Tock and the restrict act comes in
before it was terrorists now it's China
and just like before China is actually a
big threat but is it enough of a threat
for us to give up this much freedom to
give the government this much power
there are two main reasons why we might
not want to do this the one would be the
First Amendment to the Constitution
speech is protected whether you like it
or not the second reason would be is
that the constitution actually prohibits
bills of attainder you're not allowed to
have a specific bill against a person or
a company so this fails on two egregious
points pretty obvious points and I think
we ought to think about that I think we
should be aware of those who peddle fear
I think we should be aware of those who
use fear to coax Americans to relinquish
our liberties to regulate and limit our
first amendment rights every accusation
of data Gathering that's been attributed
to tick tock could also be attributed to
domestic big tech companies in fact one
of the bills they're looking at doing is
Broad enough that the president will be
given the power to designate whatever
country he sees fit to be an adversary
and whatever company underneath that
definition it would basically be a
limitless Authority for the president to
ban speech
and this is all happening as the US
loses its grip as the world's superpower
as economies all around the world are
ditching the dollar as China is uniting
our enemies as Putin is moving nukes
into Belarus and as the U.S inches
closer than ever to World War III yes we
are in turbulent times and if World War
III does break out there will be a
select few individuals that will make a
ton of money as they always have and if
you want to be one of those wealthy War
profiteers then you gotta watch our new
private documentary on the greatest war
profiteer that ever lived Dick Cheney
Dick Cheney is what many call the most
influential vice president of all time
and thanks to the war in Iraq de Cheney
is now worth an estimated 90 million
dollars and that's just an estimate and
it was all because he mastered the Dark
Art of greasing the wheels of Washington
and we expose his exact strategy in a
new private documentary that you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the screen this documentary is part of
our YouTube membership where we post
videos that are too controversial to be
monetized and members love this video
so click the card on the screen to watch
them foreign
[Music]